You know i'm just talking about it. Around a strange thing that happened to me and. I have to read if you're you can.
We went to jail guy and we painted in your bananas and our neighbor was a heroin match
and telling him about how it happened that the i have a pen and the other items in the name wouldn't that.
Sign at russian. He said. Our lease of life and the right title.
Can i mean so he said something might happen to me and he said i'm not in the he's a child or a brother
and sister might die.
And i thought that was rather strange thing to say that i don't need another short time out right now
but children don't think that. And with an item i went on with q. and A back.
Right here tonight i run a rabbit out of hand from hand to hand when i want to go into it and rather than one.
That is really true don't know about. You know reading. I don't know if i'm old and i really need a house that night.
And we're going to have a reception.
When not actually the reception the reception was held in tandem with the night that we were going to get away.
Tonight. Tonight. Right now.
For the first i had to scramble all of those down with have little insights that everything was shiny and. Plain.
So i don't know writing by writing us that's kind of you know the name. Now. All right.
But any right i got a letter that an amendment might add along the right price. For me nice not much crap.
We got married to a girl. And i'm not going to have the knighting voting for an actor. We ran to a boarding house.
And a mrs ninety had reached trade.
And she got to the reception and that of course you're going to stay there for tonight
and on the night is that the custom market just got up and i'm going to have the money. So then we went on the mat.
And i said that of course. We had no moral things to raid and everything as they do here do you remember.
An agent with the brand a praise from god because we were on his parish back
and that in a time we didn't die at all the next day.
And the next night when you didn't have that you dream of doing the things that were rather normal to me hang on
and when you have a right it's a battle to happen and kind of a thing you did you'd have at the rating.
Or kind of anything that we had.
Yes we had and i missed him around me enough to get here and i met him that you are running beautifully here.
Not just gonna see it need not only thing that. Didn't directly but i mean right i mean.
And you know that that beautifully that he has seen god.
Yes and it was dancing we had a rain that we had and i think that the name. Rainer the name.
Sorry that your family your mother and your family. Had that.
Hearing anything new about the backs of the running back was running on really meant to be said
and i think it was restored in the carrier. But because i'm running because would it not stop me from that you know.
In the morning or with custom in the morning and the right man for me when i'm in the night and the night.
We have the mailman and your apple not.
Not yet and i'm not having one and you know think of it this time right now we're going to are been exhausted after.
That's right you're right about that everybody knew that you know having a sort of you know made up. It would you know.
And gradually of mexico mccain and the younger generation come on that's you know i think.
When you get a rating a pretty good now i'm right.
You don't have to agree with me if you have a lot to do and i mean i don't run around. But i'm running and i think.
Having it are about. I think that. I think some of the bigger ratings are getting to me.
And they're kind of made everybody that i think. That is running in the rain. Right in line.
And an enjoyment in a big meeting at the other end of the sky really expensive. Ok. Will do anything.
That's right around the running that has nothing to gain from one of the red lights then that's just what kind of a
nation on the right kind of. Did you. Did you prepare right.
For many americans would have been a part of me
when you would have gotten with on trial which would probably still not me.
And that one of the neighing and it's last night and i said.
You come and i've been hanging around i think i'm driving you went on the subject in the senate. With a knife.
And you went on to borrow chicken which was that and a vegetable.
Of mashed potatoes and time again and things not back. Then you had your breakfast chicken.
Which went with a bang attack about it and i think i had messed with it and i have a bag vegetable.
And then you had your story. You ran from a number of anything i took strength.
Where writes a guy named it was me i was going to family. And it was not. X. Ray expected.
Me only because there were not everybody really run out of luck. A lot of money i mean and.
I mean my gratitude i strap it on
and now that i'm about to get ready to sign it right wrecking as much as it is have these projects here and here
and so he can rest a little he would do it but if you have your family. He got three. And already.
And about i have a friend that i used to patronize by.
And i had to represent not the kind of that and i mean it worked. And it kind of. Yes you can strap his mother in this.
And i'm going to bring in here a long time and kind of an event going to the city.
If you are right i know that eventually rolled around i know that i do not let us hear that kind of.
What's right in the writings of x. Rays or the one that came after a little bit hanging out in his you know.
If you can corner they need to go in and when i've been out of the press
and let me make sure i have that they were the he was behind he had it down. I got that and probably never looks.
And he's not and i mean this man with the looks that he had to look around and i was there
and it's right now behind the mirror that i had and he handed it out.
I mean i've read that when i read about it and i think we're going to have it ready
and then i painted in the night of the need to build a little mini.
I'm going to have an hour in a specific me on a half a second time i'm going to be there
when by the room that would be if i was at our. Thanks and i got the ax.
You know that night at midnight and it's not happening right now. I don't.
No you can't right now being a boy he had it would not be returning about i'd been dancing with one of the band.
Getting straight up to date and things straight through me and you're going to hear that which is danny
and you know everybody.
Really had a kind of man and woman with an endo
and i had to figure out which i think you've been there i've met you know anyone in the room and dancing. And i said.
I used to rules i've never tried to write a nice today. But of course. I didn't i didn't have any and that.
I never in our women. Pick on that island dancing. Just about. Just kind of mean.
Not a lot during that time but i knew that i wouldn't be allowed out. And it might matter and it ended united and me.
And i went back to work. And i just didn't. There were things that you don't do.
When you're young you're really running around in your system. You still have an email that women are about to wrap.
I didn't know much at all when my kids were going out
and whenever i went out to the tryst with the best i'm not there any media and it never used to get up around.
There were.
I had to get out of this is a good living i have a patent which i with or any other member of an astronomer about.
To a stranger at that time never liked to run around and i can't now. He's running low. And now he's running for me.
Yet again that to me. Anyway to do that and i didn't sign things night and in the night and every night.
I don't think he had many of them. And they can at any.
As you have just got to assist and about not running the system in the current system
and see the not going on as well yeah yeah yeah. And the exercise is going to be the business driving a time machine.
That's a battle that. I'm sure a lot of people let's just say an actor the thing is trying to flee.
And they're not exactly. Trying to write a good.
Lot of martin's kind that just happened a little a lot of the time you know the given ten to fifteen years things
change that a bit in the beta.
And it never really went back in seventy ad and it was really living well and his brother.
Let me have and i think for me at the rate they build anything in that and then a chance in the ones that were there.
They're not going to you know i mean. Living out anything that. Run. Yeah.
Yeah any time even when i went back and here was the right side of that you can.
Let it drop me and you straight in my little home town are in iran that get telling you it's chinese
and you're chinese he said on that when i met you right. I remember that i just couldn't believe it. Yeah me.
That green and brown that there was nothing. You know without any rhyme or in your own eyes the mystery man.
And we went to visit them it was in the path a bad thing. That is which one they found me and i don't need.
And i still have they're our me that you never used to have the same room in rival the same room
and by have this title then i still think it's back so i don't know how that i and then this made my life.
In that i have the right that i have been she rather than a very international trip. Going about it right.
But he let it run for me because i didn't remember it and i don't i didn't remember anything about it.
Found in these on the rack. It would bring him. And all that and i'm one of the things that used to run that along.
That he had done right through you. During a war you know actually during the war you're right in that sixty six.
You are right. My dad he was and you know.
The magnet for him and i don't know any of that or you know and i didn't write that
and i think you know with that changed him and. I couldn't. You know and i adore and a lot of me. I mean my maker.
And i have every nationality has their own talent you know it's really hard thing to do is right.
And by that time i think we have chinese and were really were then
and your words have a certain sympathy for the past when you look at it from the time that right.
When that was what sort of that's really kind of nice to think that it is beautiful.
That if you have a good change to me and. That it is.
You know what you think that i like when you see it it's families to that but not on it
but if you understand that you know and not.
Yes and i think enough that need to get back i think you know you have nothing else. The same guy like many guys.
You know. If you read any case at hand right now i think that in the early going to get him to me in the attack.
It was me attack him and kill the children.
And then when you're running around making nice rather than it was freaking me. Mr mann.
That arranging the englishman i suspect to tap into the mainstream meaning that seven years went by i bashfully think
very little that i missed that. I have to know they can thank you if i have to tell you i can.
If i have to my real name is. But i can understand it all. Yeah.
I'm going to remember me here here
and have told him to run a sign in english you know trying to explain something to him
and he couldn't get the right read for not five.
Driving a ten year plan wrong going to understand it but i think i mean you know.
Yes after the ride me about your hands on that piece of my neck you know rick
and i wanted to do they have any you know it's real when they have been a good few years and i went to school
and we were having a horse. And that she used to ride to school and its host. Didn't like grand rapids.
And when rather than look a man from me to me he thought i can write about her was in the running a little behind me
and that we should look at about iraq.
And he said i think i'd be getting you know that he said no
but we're going to be winning i she was right up on the scene down about a how he got on a.
Hyped up back but i'm not going to go back to manny when i mean that mcnabb.
And yet have not been there anything that you were the only good little dried up. And we kind of bad.
If you eat the banana doing.
In any group that went on a position which we had met in the beginning we couldn't get anything out of that
and we decided to try and buy some land of iran. But it was still very had to rain.
And we built a time and with one hundred i got that trying to break between trying you can become a champion
and might have been that of my brother a little more to get that battle in a distant we didn't have to see if the half.
Going to marry
and i would have been that many so i would think about how about with a brain of their own he played like.
And in the borough
and what's wrong with that enjoying you know anything with anybody so i don't have any it had rained it all ran with it
right i had the advantage to be able to happen. So many silent. That we knew that band and we sounded out.
I mean you know a little house. And i think.
Actually i think it got shifted once again and i mean right now about it or read anything you know.
Me from about iraq for the for the little thing and main things i'm not.
It's only available right by about half of what i need it with granted some of them. If you plan it.
When we moved right. And we planted moment nonis being the true.
We have to make the right green bananas runs i'm gonna have a good price. I'm gonna buy bread so we had good. Landlady.
I think of the type of thirty i could between us.
And that mean that we had to play and want to happen with a very rocky. And nat.
On the fact that we had no events really banks but then my brother and i and my brother
and brother in the immediate times i had high paid.
And replanted of dying on this rocky mountain a lot of the time and of no not really good bananas.
And i never said robbie that we have to migrate to plant them and i wanted to win the sack of kind not.
And i'm just an ordinary cow about whether or not.
I mean you know i had to use the actual i think i'm an engram heineman he found to be idling in the north
and south thing i've got pains are in me out of them and you've got a guy. That's going to count.
Axel right opinions of them are right. That seminary had a very rocky and.
When we had to have a hole with a tag on it on a stand with a hose that's not what they were going to be to money so we
brought.
And it will kind of bring out a track that we can really get might not go over the cracks about the middle kind of
thing that i need with many snow. And it will be my job to drive it.
That the manana scene and all of that are right here believe you me and i am behaving.
Would have made a big version of an advantage.
He had grown around for in china under an armed dragon at the time we need a little fact.
And a good arriving at a good. And i know. Rice name from the bottom and right of the take you know guy i remember.
I don't know what we were doing about me pulling them out and hang around.
And i was driving as usual and the sound of rain. Me.
That tracks on the caterpillar track down pulled it down nappy headed on top of a never stand which triggered that sort
of the track that i did was on the start of a hill. And i can just so the track been going. And i hit me right jam.
And of course i john. The luck of the not happened just after you know. If i jumped down hill i jumped up and.
Thankfully thank god would have to store a little. I don't reckon with a round on me.
From the me forever with that of anything right you going out.
Over many guys then we had to push it back pretty bad but you know i'm bad and i got it with many many.
Write me a phony baloney. I mean let's face it when he thought jonathan are going down he went really well you know.
You could do that but any right not bring it on and we could go on a plane and i thought out.
I mean even met not because i'm going to go.
Ok but in the right and it got me down
and then after a round we decided we'd try to mend that going to davy found out and gave me.
The maker of the monotonous. Little stool.
To throw in with the room with me i mean it with me in it and
when he comes try to write down into the night of the tank. Come to writing month.
Just back from when you're playing them it's uniting not that that's not just never going to be visible.
So remember the band and babies in between the. You know. We've done a rap.
That regularly will be that the build up to hit any right. And remove the bat signal right jean. And then.
Know that that time was to with my brother in law.
And my brother in law ronald i mean we're all of them ripping down my hand.
That we had there been a machine that you know yes we had the european machine i mean it had written the making of the
united kingdom.
Some time in the morning which is dying are going to think you know we know we've got to admit i don't think we're
going to die very much where you know he died not. Then of course and when the cistern on i did the milking then.
Not in the morning and i went to found it in between which to rip them out. We had to chant.
I'm going to have that good at the height
when she photographed me that checking the grass around the room with this bright organized guy how to read have to
read with a had a chip
or a woman out in between the monotonous with the highway which you were going mad mad world at the wrong thing to do
and i wouldn't have surprise much in the beginning.
Because when you move the top for the next run it will get right to right.
Whereas you can just ride the story would be in the newsroom.
Found out of the top three little one of the last rites of mission on the hill.
But of course you would in that time low ranking thing that we did in the king. And i remember one morning.
In a very odd looking machines had been hiding out and. It runs batted down. The section.
Wooden the right side of the baby actually wish ange would put it off if you put them on the cans.
And every one of the five hundred children about that had to be putting.
And that was kind of happen and i thought i think that it might have been which the machines are.
And then when i said right.
He tricked it on the guy that you know never made it but i had to really go at it when it turned up in the rain.
I was going to write i was drawn and i just stopped the rail.
From spinning out of what it would have been just trying my hand at me
and i have chatted up things that got me to say he made the china doll. Just automatically.
Samurai brad and i had back.
You know you break your arm you know it's a rag and yeah about me i'm not in any bad run by anyone and.
On the side but i have to have a lot of growth that many difficulties
and i need to be good at the same time i have them. Up and stop and go back i need back and i my brother.
Here with all of the time got shingle that.
He couldn't read them and i've been in the opening round hand me
when i asked not to run around many many children i was crowded with the middle of the one hand. You know.
And my sister in law and i carried on there were no children at that night
but yes i know you know if i had to endure the mistral didn't.
That i had to have you know it was brought to think that this guy had to have bad.
And i think a lot of the children would rather than that door would you go again
and i will let you know that they haven't done it with me and run. The night that you know.
I mean the children all together and. I don't have to tell me i don't rule out of the you know i said.
But i think i could have come up around ten out of they were going to have a problem
and i was a little behind the hard times when right. Is that right i had time for that frederick to do.
And i mean if you didn't believe in you couldn't balance i will think of this like you did
and i just pounded on a lot of the right. Of that both of the children that.
I never started it and i had to go right at the end.
And then she ran off to jail and you got tended not to
and you've got to try to create an environment to train your thanks to you and then on high school.
And let's not get me wrong and it's me i thought about it and you know. Richmond you know may not be any high school.
Around in iraq and i don't mean you know about going to bed but i've got a. Well i think it was called the lady.
And with run it was called the high school certificate. In the correct me. Yes but that about that.
How many years between seventy and seventy. Not to because i think i have interviewed a couple of them to train me.
You know that at night.
Writing running on any of the leisure a little monetary gains you know she was really really good woman.
Which helped me a lot and read that anything that means you know got the name down there from the united.
Schoolteacher the gist of it. Trying ukraine. To manage him.
And run it right i'm talking about ronnie is here with us now because the thing is you know it's good when he went.
Sydney before you. And many were down there.
He got mad when he was down there and i'm not working with danny my friend
and we think of that picture right of not going to change.
The bus he was working for a bookshop in town and said could they come back.
They could come back and with me if i wanted to.
World if i did not return to writing i'm not actually writing and writing or the kind that wouldn't normally anyway.
There was no time for i think i'm back with sam i read. Sydney pretty good in the.
We're not trying to kind of the strength of a run up as machine when you think you know that's what happened.
And we kind of make kind that i don't like it when i think you know that one.
And i think good now i'm going to handle that you know which is great i like having to handle it.
How many grandchildren all together. All right. And i'm going to train three girls you know.
And i'm going to have the ability. And ever and i think he's let me make a lot and you know. I have been told that.
Yes i have been tainted and she is a trying not to be trying when we're sort of just going with going to think.
I think. I think it's a good idea that. It's a pretty big something. I'm not sure what i mean and i'm saying.
I've met him and i think that that's going on and you know if you guys go away. You know and i think it was on days.
I think maybe it would have made a big school. Would have been a big school in maine.
It's a catholic school but rather than relieving the catholics going over thing i would think that the right. Pages.
There were not the nice you know. He is not very many not a stand united i mean you know.
Heavenly you know to write your great read it again you know i think the natural the way we witness started.
To maybe in detail. When you were nineteen seventeen.
Coming in i decided that i really didn't like family but never a lot calmer
but much actually trying to get a job in town.
Which i did i have regretted my own factory which was then any i think since then i'm going to see the apparel.
Seventy i used to work on main street our the. I stayed there for about eight g. Which that's a lot.
Maker of or even matter right used to run very much at risk your money coming in and without any new aftermath.
Three months after we may need it if you had back. Really bad at around him.
And he had to have an operation not to have a newsgroup man you and he were the right.
For every union over here our lives with the bananas to read and a job at the factory. I didn't know anything.
Give me back to you about the good meaning of the money.
Car i would be working with monotonous and waking me up more than jade
when you had brought in jade that were going to run down on from friday night
and cut banana on the side down from the front and i mean i've made them here.
To kill the cheese that when i would go right on the try.
What i used to be ashamed to drive the bananas in with a jeep with a banana geyser on its own.
Having a packet of fare i arrived with that great many in my lunch hour drive out of that type of bananas
and i would then. And i'm tired i get back for a long time and eventually my brother a little below.
The anonymous tip is run down or i remember i think you know the route.
It was boring running and making it down enough to bring him over the twenty one of twenty two guys on the trial
or behind a pro and i tracked down the girl. That it was it was too heavy.
And i had that body kind of the head with drags on not that i didn't want to my concrete kind of run out of them over
on and on down and down the hill. Track just looked at it a bit and one of the tracks went out.
I used to go around it and i know none of me floored me again.
With my barrel just got that word in full with until i went back again.
But there i am i'm not going to be saving a little money kinds of them but none of them a crime.
And i think i think i'm gonna tell me i'm not back but the fact that.
I've made randy in five zero which is the new era.
I'm in and i need to do it with a light behind the counter banana and i know that might not have come out
and a lot of the young men from me
and coming to town that's were not really were drawn into making any headway to having me. Operation out of the map.
And i can remember i used to come in every night to me getting around that give me pain with clean records.
I mean you're going to be offended i know. And i could have cried. With another five times.
And i've never i've been you know what i had a problem with that
and you know he's going to have he's telling me it's going very little.
Around and around and i think i have traction on him to try moving back maybe a minute.
And i just grew to a power i feel of a doctor that tom and i think will work and we did it
when he sent me anything you can operation.
That we have to have the right you know we're thrilled right back by were much better after that.
But i doubt he wouldn't have been never i mean you know anybody who would read he wrote.
Just about a little economy and not getting a job and he was really saying me.
Which he wouldn't pay a premium and i thought that detain me and that town. Sort of.
We went on for a mate of mine and eventually i mean i look around.
I don't you know broke been you know we decided together we're going to go back to me and i've broke
and then we went to a bad name the rule about not having the right age.
And we had found a found when we came to means we'll get the founder of our own for a ban on the sixteen i think.
When we return our look around a little and a half and then exactly what would you like a minute.